I can't think of any more human activity
conducting science experiments.
That's what we do as human beings and we
do that more thoroughly and better than
any other species on earth that we have
yet encountered.
We explore our environment more than we
are compelled to utter poetry.
When were toddlers,
we start doing that later.
Before that happens,
every child is assigned.
I think about it.
What do kids do?
Young kids,
kids that can barely walk.
What are they doing?
They're exploring their environment
through experimentation.
I don't care about your economic
background.
I don't care what town you're born in,
what city,
what country.
If you're a child,
you are curious about your environment,
your overturning rocks.
You're plucking leaves off of trees and
pedals off of flowers and looking inside
and you're doing things that create
disorder in the lives of the adults
around you.
And so then what do adults do?
They say,
don't pluck the pedals off the flowers.
I just spent money on that.
Don't play with the egg.
It might break.
Don't everything is a don't.
I'm often asked by parents,
what advice can I give them to help get
kids interested in science?
And I have only one bit of advice.
Get out of their way.
Kids are born curious period.
We spend the first year of teaching them
to walk and talk and the rest of their
lives tell him to shut up and sit down
so you get out of their way.
You know you do and you put things in
their myths that help them explore,
help them explore.
Once you get a pair of binoculars,
just leave it there one day.
Watch and pick it up and watch them look
around.
They'll do all kinds of things with it.
For me,
at age 11 I had a pair of binoculars and
I looked up to the moon and the moon
wasn't just bigger,
it was better.
There were mountains and valleys and
craters and shadows and it came alive.
I was transformed by picking up a pair
of binoculars looking up.
And so when I think of science,
I think of a truly human activity,
something fundamental to our DNA,
something that drives curiosity.
They go together.
The act of being curious and the act of
wanting to do the experiment.
When you conduct science,
it is the natural world that is the
ultimate decider and what is true and
what is not.
You have to create what it is that you
do best that layers onto the formal
training that may be behind it.
I think the greatest of people that have
ever been in society,
they were never versions of someone
else.
They were themselves.
The great tragedy,
people employed in ways that don't fully
tap everything they do best in life.
And so I think the greatest of people in
society carve niches that represented
the unique expression of their
combinations of talents.
And if everyone had the luxury of
expressing the unique combinations of
talents in this world,
our society would be transformed
overnight.